Charlie Munger has made a dire warning
about the real estate market in America
a lot of real estate isn't so good
anymore we have a lot of troubled Office
Buildings a lot of troubled shopping
centers a lot of troubled other
properties there's a lot of Agony out
there
Charlie Munger is Warren Buffett's
legendary business partner and according
to him the real estate market is in deep
trouble but this time it's not centered
around normal homes like it was in 2008.
now this time the crisis is with
commercial real estates like offices and
shopping centers Regional Bank stocks
have taken a major hit on Wall Street in
recent weeks with Pac West leading the
slide one reason is their commercial
real estate Investments are losing value
many buildings are sitting empty with
remote work from the covet pandemic and
it's going to be ugly I mean it's going
to be at least as bad as 0809 in fact
it's so bad that half of all Office
Buildings in America are sitting vacants
and for the banks these commercial real
estate loans are a ticking Time Bomb
after 2008 we all assume that Banks had
learned their lesson we bail them out in
hopes that they wouldn't screw us over
again by gambling our money but as
Charlie Munger famously said show me the
incentive and I'll show you the outcome
stay dangerous and this is the
commercial real estate crisis
in the United States and elsewhere in
the world it's going to be quite
significant and quite unpleasant
if I were in your shoes I would be going
hard learning everything I can about Ai
and how to make money from this AI
Revolution because there is generational
wealth to be made right now but if
you're gonna be making AI money you're
gonna need a great wallet to store all
that cash and the wallet I've been using
every day for the past three years that
I still get a ton of compliments on is
my extra wallets extra is hands down the
best smart wallet out there period there
is no competition even though I can
afford it I still take this over a Louis
Vuitton wallet that costs 10 times more
any day of the week it's got a quick
access trailer that is oddly satisfying
to use it's RFID blocking it's got a
strap for cash but my favorite part is
that you get all of this while still
looking classy thanks to his premium lwg
silver rated leather the one I have is
their Senate model which is the one I
recommend and I also just got their
beautiful laptop sleeve it's the perfect
mix of minimalism functionality and
classiness just like their wallets and
that's exactly what I needed get up to
35 off during Essence Father's Day Sale
May 16th to June 20th when you use the
code Jake Trend at checkout or shop
using the linkshop.exer.com support
pause the video and click the link below
right now to get the last wallet you
will ever need thanks to extra for
sponsoring this video
foreign
Banks hold more than 2.9 trillion
dollars in commercial mortgages and all
that commercial real estate is currently
going down the drain that's because most
of these mortgages are tied up in
properties like offices and shopping
centers places that have just been
decimated ever since covered forced
everyone to work from home and Shop
remotely even though it's been almost
two years after covet peaked most people
still choose to work remotely or they
only go into the office for a few days a
week this has turned a ton of massive
Office Buildings that used to be full of
people into creepy commercial ghost
towns like this this and this
commercial ghost house that aren't
making their owners any money leaving
them in a massive amount of unpayable
debts it's kind of like if you bought a
bunch of homes rented them out and then
all of a sudden half of your tenants
leave that is exactly what's happening
right now only around 50 of America's
Office Buildings are actually being used
50 think about how insane that is the
other half are sitting empty and racking
up a ton of interest and it's about to
get a lot worse I see a tsunami of of
loans coming due that can't be uh can't
be refinanced see more than half of the
commercial mortgages out there right now
a good 1.5 trillion dollars of real
estate debts is about to come up for
refinancing meaning that the owners of
this commercial real estate are gonna
have to come in soon to get a new
mortgage rate and their new mortgage
rate is going to be whatever mortgage
rates happen to be at that time which is
very bad timing because at the same time
the FED has been pushing interest rates
higher than ever before which means that
once these commercial mortgages are
refinanced their monthly payments are
gonna go through the roof these office
management companies that bought offices
at an interest rate of 0.5 percent are
now going to have to pay a five percent
interest rates so on top of their
tenants leaving their loan payments are
gonna explode which means more and more
commercial real estate owners are gonna
default just like what happened in 2008
but instead of residential homes it's
commercial real estate just take a look
at Brookfield the largest office owner
in downtown Los Angeles chose the
default on loans on two buildings rather
than refinance due to the weak demand
for office space and this isn't just
some one-off thing Brookfield is the
biggest owner of office space in
Downtown LA so if one of the biggest
commercial property owners in the
country is giving up how is everyone
else faring that's what Charlie Munger
meant when he said that banks are
refilled to the brim with bad loans
loans that probably won't get repaid and
once businesses everywhere start
defaulting under commercial real estate
loans who is going to be left holding
the bag the banks of course
do you think what's happening now could
cause more Banks to fail I mean
absolutely you could see bigger Banks
get in trouble you can see a run on all
small Regional Banks and that could put
us right back to where we were with the
financial crisis of 08 right now the
problems in commercial real estate
aren't nearly as bad as they were in
2008 but that doesn't mean there's
nothing to worry about quote Morgan
Stanley analysts estimate that Banks
hold as much as 70 percent of commercial
real estate loans that mature over the
next five years End quotes five years
that is the ticking Time Bomb we're
looking at and if borrowers aren't
planning on paying back those loans
banks are gonna have to foreclose on
those properties and try to resell them
which is where the next problem comes in
even if they try to resell them
commercial property prices drop by 15 in
March alone that's a huge shot for just
one month and there's a chance
commercial property prices might fall by
as much as 40 in the next few months so
if banks end up for closing on these
commercial real estate properties even
if they try to sell these foreclosed
properties they won't get anywhere near
the amount they need people's retirement
investment sir tied up in real estate
like this all over the country all over
the country and in every major city
because these were seen as very safe
Investments I think the next two years
are going to be very very difficult so
is the perfect storm for commercial
Banks since 2008 banks have only gotten
more and more risky once more they've
been cutting Corners taking risks thanks
gamble with the amount of money they
lent out all because they were betting
on the fact that most businesses were in
the perfect position to make their loan
payments but that is not the case
anymore if these Banks don't get enough
money back from their foreclosures
they're not going to have enough money
on hand which is going to put them at
risk of the same bank runs we saw with
svb if people start suspecting banks are
running out of money they're going to
pull their money out of banks as fast as
possible so even more small and
medium-sized banks are gonna go the same
way as svb the only question is will the
government bail them out too the answer
is yes the government literally has no
choice it's either bail out the posters
or it will be Financial Armageddon and
Warren Buffett seems to think so too
quote if the government allowed the
positives to lose money it would cost
Bank runs across the country and disrupt
the entire Global Financial system that
is not the way the us is going to behave
um
according to Munger pull every Bank in
the country is way tighter on real
estate loans today than they were six
months ago they all seem to be in too
much trouble End quotes as a whole loans
from commercial Banks dropped by 105
billion dollars in just the last two
weeks of March that is a huge drop they
spent all this time risking it all and
now these Banks suddenly want to
implement reasonable lending practices
it's like Monger said in Good Times you
get into bad habits and then when bad
times come you lose too much and when
more than 270 billion dollars in
commercial mortgages held by Banks set
to expire this year it's only a matter
of time until we find out just how much
of depositor's money the banks gambled
we could see something worse let's face
it and when they inevitably fail again
you can guarantee that BlackRock would
be hard to clean up the mess as usual
and also as usual you will be the one
paying for it if you think the next few
years are gonna be pretty difficult and
you want to start stacking a lot of cash
to prepare you might want to take the
route that I took when I was first
getting started see back when I was 19 I
was just as awkward kid and community
Unity College that didn't have a degree
and had hardly any experience what I
really really wanted to make money
online so I tried everything graphic
design stock trading and so on but as a
teenager without any experience
obviously those business ideas didn't
work so I thought I might as well try
Landing a work from home job to hold me
over I was reading a lot of marketing
and psychology books at the time and
that's when it hit me I realized that
applying for jobs is not about how much
experience you have on paper no it's
about how good you are at marketing
yourself my theory was that if I
marketed myself well I can maybe beat
the boring application with a lot more
experience so I went ham applying all
the marketing and psychology principles
I was learning into my job application
and it worked I remember being on a
family trip with my parents and my phone
was blowing up with companies hitting me
up and one of them ended up hiring me
for a 40 per hour work from home job at
only 19 years old without a degree in
hardly any experience to put that into
context that's around 80 000 a year at
full-time hours at 19 years old and this
job changed my entire life I was able
the drop off College I made a ton of
money all while having the time to work
on what would become this YouTube
channel and because work from home jobs
changed my life forever I decided to
take this framework that I developed and
I put it into a master class so you too
can learn a war from home job without a
degree even if you're starting from zero
like I was this is the best course out
there on how to get a work from home job
because not only has it worked for me
but it's worth for our other students
long story short one of them landed a 25
per hour position living in South Africa
and another landed on the same position
where he got equity in the company the
company got Acquired and he made Bank
from a stock going up so if this sounds
interesting to you and you want to learn
more click the square on the screen to
watch our quick video explaining it
click the square on the screen to watch
now
[Music]
thank you